Now we consider the implementation of the all-important page
table data structure, which needs to translate virtual page numbers
into physical page frames. Virtual page numbers start at
zero, and then go up by one. So the most
straightforward way to do this would be to create
a giant array that is the number of pages long.
Let's see how this strategy might work. Suppose that we
have a 48-bit virtual address and 32-bit physical address and
let's say pages of sizes 4K. We've used up 12 bits for the offset, leaving 2 to
the 36 possible virtual page numbers. That means
that we need an array 2 to the 36
long, each entry probably having 4 bytes to
specify the physical address, which brings us to a
total of about 256 gigs. Which is more memory
than most machines have in RAM. And of course,
almost all of it is wasted since most virtual addresses
aren't used. Even with just 32 bit virtual addresses, we
would still need a page table with 2 to the
20th entries. And that would put us on the order of
several megabytes. And of course we need one page table
per process. So instead, page tables are done in a hierarchical
way. In our 32-bit example, the highest order 10 bits
are used as an index into a top level page table.
The contents of this page table then give us
the base address of another page table. We use the
next 10 bits as the index into that lower
level page table. And the contents of that page table
then give us the physical page number. Why does
this help us use less memory? Well recall our virtual
address space. We use addresses at the bottom, and
we use addresses at the top. But there's a vast
empty region in the middle. Many of these
unused addresses will have the same 10 higher order
bits. And for these, we won't even have a
secondary table. Thus, we end up using not too
much more memory for the page table than we
really need to. The particulars of the actual page
implementation vary greatly. Some have three levels, others have
four. But they all use this basic hierarchical strategy.